six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go next to the six zero nine area
code six zero nine go ahead yeah hey
Dave can you hear me yeah good all right
so we hear a lot of our slippery slope
talk in regards to the Second Amendment
they can pick apart the you know
progressives are allowed to dismantle
the Second Amendment or change it could
the alt-right then proceeded to do a lot
of damage to a lot of progressive you
know progress that's the new I mean so
if I understand the question correctly
you're saying if the left is able to
pass gun safety legislation would that
in some way enabled the right to undo
progressive progress but like what are
you thinking of specifically well
legislation that's all a matter of our
interpretation actually my question
today or comment it has to do with the
First Amendment in regards to the
Russian or alleged Russian hacking what
I want to know is if people can be
censored on what they're saying does
that create a slippery slope oh all the
Russians did could to my knowledge
there's been no evidence whatsoever a
single vote actually being flipped and
changed and I understand that it was
indeed a hostile country like Russia
that flooded no Facebook basically and
other social media with a lot of a
propaganda yeah propaganda has always
been used in warfare I understand but
that's all it is is propaganda is the
issue the propaganda or is issue the
feeble-minded Americans that were so
susceptible to it and if we were to
coddle or to swaddle these feeble minds
of Americans exactly how far does that
go
you're now censoring what people can say
who's to say that it's going to be
limited to just Russian operatives or
the nationalist Network okay you got it
got it I think I understand he got me
think I understand so that there's a
couple different issues here right one
is your spot on how was such a
significant portion of the American
public so stupid as to vote for Donald
Trump such that a foreign influence
propaganda campaign might have might
have made the difference that's that's a
really really good question to be asking
it's separate from just the legality of
foreign dollars influencing American
elections right that you we can debate
whether that should or shouldn't be the
law and we can also debate how sad it is
that so many Americans were bamboozled
by Trump's own propaganda and Russian
propaganda supporting him but we do have
laws about the financing of elections
and those laws at least as far as the
indictments are concerned from robert
muller those laws were broken so it's
two different things and it's important
not to conflate them you know well
that's all this thing is propaganda if
that's what I'm hearing
financing okay so maybe they paid for
their propaganda that's right that's
exactly right that's a way that would be
a violation of campaign finance law and
where does that end I mean you can look
at the law I'm not mistaken I forget the
exact guys name but there was a
publisher they yanked on I think he was
a radio host that Yankers book off of
the publication list because he had a
lot of Nazi all right sentiment ology in
it ah not akin to modern-day book
burning no it's not I mean it's a
private business deciding that it's bad
business for them to publish that book
you know I think this is the problem and
I and I got a run you're conflating like
three or four different issues and
making them all part of the same
slippery slope argument which is in and
of itself sort of logically fallacious
so I try to disaggregate some of these
issues and and sort of think through
them in a slightly different way like a
publisher saying we don't know we don't
want to do business with a writer
because of the content of the book is
not the same as campaign finance laws
and it none of it has anything to do
with the second amendment so I I
disaggregate some of these issues well
life very much indeed is very
complicated
yes it
they will you go ahead and run along all
right I'll run along thank you
appreciate you releasing me to do to
live my life I appreciate that we'll
take a quick break and we will be back
with more of your phone calls after this
if you're holding don't hang up because
we're going right back to the phones
after the break